dort wird gesponsert vom toyota auris
hybrid
er braucht keine steckdose und wer
trotzdem elektrisch
[Musik]
dabei
ja ja ja ins kühle nass
das neue ist oft wahl kommt das ist ja
typisch schönstes gibt es jetzt bei
manchen oder halte meine tiere besonders
und gleichzeitig wusste dass das land
wieder zu langen wirkung
ja das ist es so abreiben das gehört die
landwirtschaft zu können
also ich leben und sterben auf dem
bauernhof
für fein gemacht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja
[Musik]
wird es sie dass auf diesem hof im
zürcherischen meilen soeben ein kalb zur
welt gekommen ist
oder macht es sie hungrig oder sowohl
als auch
[Musik]
reto weber betreibt mutter tierhaltung
die als besonders tierfreundlich geld
das heißt die kälbchen bleiben so lange
bei der mutter bis irgendwann ein
lastwagen vorfährt und sie zur
schlachtung abholt am anfang habe ich
nur vorschläge mehr chaos geld rasiert
und social media
es ist außerdem eine kommunikative hause
metzger er hat sich geschossen und auch
eine hand mit der us-bürger und ich
hatte hausen und hebt natürlich könnte
ich das heute aber das hat mit so viel
weniger gemacht also dass sich eine
familie aus aussee vor 15 jahren so
komisch ist in russland kurz heißt das
nötig wie viele briefe wurden weniger
investiert oder klar was das liegt aber
ich hoffe das gefühl dass sie ende sind
die metalle wo der bkk 24
[Musik]
helen gerber ist tierkommunikatorin sie
sorgt also sie können mit ihren reden
und dass ich aus unserem verhältnis zu
tieren viel über uns menschen heraus
schließen lasse wenn ich das nicht
achtsam mit dem tier um grau sorgfältig
oder speck nach ob er vertrauen
auszusprechen
wie das geht das schon
[Musik]
viele menschen nehmen tiere als wesen
war die ein bewusstsein haben einen
willen und gefühle sie sind davon
überzeugt dass tiere uns sehr ähnlich
sind und dass wir sie entsprechend
behandelt sollten
[Musik]
gleichzeitig gibt es nutztiere wie reto
webers kürzlich geborenen kälbchen
nennen wir es luca tiere deren messung
und tötung unserer gesellschaft in einem
gewaltigen ausmaß perfektioniert hat
tiere die man besser nicht zu sehr ins
herz schließt ich streiche das verwöhnen
ich glaube dass im bett sein abstand
genau aus dem grund der plaques an
flotten schritts absturz für sie ja ja
das ist so ja
der absturz es ist richtig ein nutztier
ist etwas ganz anderes als ein haustier
heißt es die einen sollen wir essen die
anderen streicheln wer nutzt herren
allerdings täglich in die augen sieht
der muss sich anstrengen damit er nicht
plötzlich mehr in ihnen sieht als die
vorstufe eines fleisch produktes diese
menschen wollen nicht nur mit tieren
fühlen sondern auch mit ihnen reden
sowie helen gerber die diesen kurs
leitet und sich regelmäßig mit
vierbeinern austauscht kürzlich zum
beispiel mit einer hirschkuh dann habe
ich die hirschkuh gefragt was sagst du
mir über gott und dann sagte die jetzt
kurz vor mir gott ist überall
gott ist im gras dass ich es sehr im
wasser das ich trinke und im korb das
ich führe das war wunderschön und dann
sagte ich zur terrier spätest du denn
auch und dann sagte sie ich bin ein
gebiet
und dann sagte ich du bist so schön und
sie sagte ja ich bin ein schönes gebe
während der laie über soviel tierischen
tiefgang staunt begeben sich die
angehenden tier telepathie innen an den
rand des denkvermögens dorthin wo
vielleicht erleuchtung hat vielleicht
ein hirn richtet das glück möglichst
fair bewusst die entwickler für was was
es dir ähnlich ist es dass
persönlichkeiten dass die sehr wohl
mitbekommen was mir mit denen machen
natürlich ist jeder mensch und ich dann
das haus milch oder der katastrophen
oder erfolges klarinette spezies ist
aber wenn man sie mit dem lande zurück
das möchte
wer wie martin willmann als jäger erfolg
haben will der geht besser nicht auf
tiere zu sondern beobachtet sie auf
distanz
von einem hochsitz aus bühl man wartet
jeweils auf den richtigen moment und
drückt ab wie bei seiner ersten beute
einem hirsch
das hier ist wirklich wirklich tot
gesehen ist das für das gefühl sie ist
schwarz zum jäger herbstlichen flächig
und so schwang schon ein flüchtiger dass
das gelungen ist aber dass ich jetzt das
eine ist machte das noch seither hat
will man unzählige stunden auf der lauer
verbracht weit weg von seinem früheren
alltag als logopäde weit weg von seiner
frau und den inzwischen erwachsenen
kindern
er ist gern allein allein mit sich und
der natur
[Musik]
bühlmann hat ihre gern viele von ihnen
sogar zum fressen gern
das war für ihn nie ein widerspruch er
hat schon unzählige vierbeiner getötet
und zubereitet auch solche die für viele
von uns nicht auf den teller sondern auf
den shows gehören zum beispiel katzen
und sie bekommen nach hause nehmen
hallo sagt er dazu aber füßen gefesselte
befangen weil sie sie müsse das ist
sogar immer gesagt was ich für mich sei
das haus oder hugo sollen sie sind nie
irgendwie befragten ihr widerstand tasse
deshalb die erste heim
dazu gehört ich bin aufgewachsen meine
große haushalt nein das mittagsmahl
arbeiter und verbraucher verstehen dass
arbeitszeit verstand der kaigasse
möglichst viel fleisch freiheit wenn
bauern zu viele katzen hatten war
bühlmann während jahrzehnten ein
dankbarer abnehmer
er erlegte sie und machte daraus pfeffer
katzen pfeffer was löst das in ihnen aus
abscheu unverständnis wieso eigentlich
um diese fragen zu beantworten steigen
wir tief in die menschliche seele hinab
zusammen mit einem ortskundigen führer
den psychiater frank urbaniok erstaunt
es nicht dass derselbe mensch selber
essen aber den gedanken an katzenfleisch
unerträglich finden kann
hunde und katzen auf dem konto haustiere
und
einzelne individuum gebucht sind also es
sind in unserer gesellschaft sind das
lebewesen die den menschen sehr nahe
stehen meine hauskatze die ist nicht
anonym
es ist nicht die katze sondern ist eine
bestimmte katze und immer wenn es
bestimmte lebewesen sind die unsere sind
dann wird tendenziell eher empathie
zugehörigkeit aktiviert deswegen
reagieren wir extrem empfindlich darauf
wenn man sich vorstellt die werden
gegessen
auch wenn man objektiv sagen konnte
wirklich was ist der unterschied
zwischen einem und einer katze oder
einem karl ja was ist eigentlich der
unterschied zwischen einer katze oder
einem hund und diesem kalb inzwischen
ist luca vier monate alt und hat bereits
zwei lungenentzündungen hinter sich
zurückhaltend sich ähnlich
das rund sicher da wo ich hasse müssen
zweimal gewann das heißt mehrere tag und
das ist wirklich das gott eine grenze
tochter war das thema spritze warum das
weiß genau dass von mir oder von
mitarbeitern mal spritzen bekommen und
bis die tatsache die der gast gottes
alte lernen gibt es überhaupt einen
unterschied zwischen luca und den hunden
und katzen die bei vielen gerber herum
spazieren oder bilden wir uns diesen
unterschied nur ein
ich glaub es ist etwas was auch sinn
york die intelligenz also zum beispiel
mini 300 euro ganz ganz verschieden vom
naturell trifft ist das ist strategie
und ein wenig besser schlafen doch und
damit weg genau in dem moment wo
fruchtig des statikers nach luft mit
also das ganze bewusst danken die
waschen hält das tier dann hinter den
taliban zu entwickeln und
persönlichkeitsentwicklung
[Musik]
könnte es sein dass luca eine
persönlichkeit entwickeln würde wenn wir
es nur zulassen würden
[Musik]
man muss es vermuten angesichts der
tatsache dass offenbar sogar hühner zu
einem echten gegenüber werden können
das hat nichts mit telepathie das tier
kümmert oder gar nicht was es heißt
operandi konditionierung auf gebildete
weiß nicht genau aber es funktioniert
auch mit denen die ihr konntet
telepathische verbindet das hdtv
konditionen seines hohen frage was die
momente so beschäftigt die frage zum
beispiel das wissen was beschäftigte im
moment dass die laster tour also das was
wir hier machen außer zu hilfe dass es
gut kommt und das ist dem zusammenhang
gerissen also dass ich heute sitzt nicht
paris ist das fraglich ist wie so oft
wie das noch häufig tv ist wenn man mit
ihr telefoniert der blitzstart mit
drogen sondern häufig trage ich ganz weg
und ruhe dort wie ich sie damals jetzt
einfach dass was passiert als er
meditiert das nicht unhöflich gemeint
ist mit dem gespräch gesagt du bist nur
für ca
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
soeben ging es keine persönlichkeit an
den kragen sondern einem ordinären nun
dass keine eier mehr legte und darum für
den bauern wertlos wurde
es müssen in der erste schlag muss
92 na gut gespielt und ich glaube das
hat mit sport und insofern ist mir
eigentlich das normalerweise während
diese tiere getötet und weggeworfen
worden
denn das interesse an zehn suppenhühner
die vor dem verzehr ausgenommen gerupft
werden müssen hält sich in engen grenzen
nicht so bei wie man der findet auch
diese wesen hätten es verdient verwertet
zu werden
[Musik]
das ist die einen streicheln wir die
anderen essen wir
und die die wir essen essen viele von
uns nur dann wenn sie ihnen zu lebzeiten
nie in die augen geschaut haben
dass ich das bin ich ja ja wie viel
fleisch würden sie noch essen wenn es
nicht mehr abgepackt im supermarkt lege
wenn sie das tier zuerst töten und dann
selber verarbeiten müssten aber das
haben jetzt ja da ist sein motto
aber ich tue das dorf schmiede und
christa und da gibt es ein wunderbarer
blick
ich sehe da etwas das schockiert mich
das ekelt mich an und das ist ein thema
und dann sitze ich von meinem teller und
esse das aber das ist etwas anderes da
liegt halt etwas auf dem teller was
schon hundert mal auf dem teller gelegen
hat und der die verbindung wird nicht
gemacht
in der wahrnehmung ist es das gleiche ob
ich eine banane kaufe oder ob hier ein
stück fleisch kaufe es ist in einem
gewissen kontext eingeordnet und wird in
dessen kontext auch dann dem kunden
präsentiert das macht es leichter sich
dem widerspruch nicht zu stellen
und solche widersprüche gibt es viele
zum beispiel auch dass sie sich von
bühlmann zu seiner dünne brühe einladen
lassen aber dann könnt ablehnen würden
wenn er folgendes konto und seelisch
niederstaufen und die bier macht über
den mord sagt haupt wie es sich gehört
lorbeerblätter und woche dran doch auch
bisher tag
abgerechnet wird und hoffe dass führte
sie zu einer karriere als regisseur
nimrod wieder zu
wir essen im durchschnitt rund 50 kilo
fleisch pro jahr
um dieses fleisch produzieren zu können
muss reto weber innerhalb seines
viehbestandes eine emotionale mauer
ziehen zwischen denen die gemästet und
geschlachtet werden und denen die ihm
nahe kommen wie seine lieblingskuh
junger mann sitzt sich ruhe game
ich hoffe der trainer denn sie haben
speziell ist auch ganze flotte ist ja
eines tages wenn sie nicht mehr trächtig
wird wird ilona wertlos für weber 100
wird auch sie in die metzgerei geben
müssen
vor diesem tag graut ihm allerdings
schon jetzt denn die beiden stehen sich
nahe wirklich normal
es wird natürlich dass bildung
krankenhaus mit drin oder so und
mittelinseln hamit altintop oder andere
wo also in schuss sind überall nur
bilder mit kindern der familie das ist
nicht so das 1 0 vor angst überhaupt
nicht das ist einfach der eex bereich
von gewohnheiten gestalten
die einen kühe sind einfach für für ihn
und die anderen kühe sind viel mehr als
das
sobald man das individuum identifiziert
so bald nicht mehr eine anonyme masse
ist dann spielt empathie kann empathie
eine rolle spielen indem man mitfühlt
man kann sich gut evolutionär vorstellen
woher das kommt dass man irgendwann in
der evolution davon profitiert hat das
ist eine enge zusammengehörigkeit
zwischen sieben mitgliedern gab und dass
die sippe umso stärker war umso mehr sie
nicht nur ein sammelsurium von egoisten
war sondern etwas wie ein team gedanken
wie eine verbundenheit entwickelt hat
und da dürfte empathie der kitt der
leyen gewesen sein der dann diese
einzelnen menschen in einem netzwerk
miteinander verbunden hat und
evolutionär waren diese netzwerke viel
erfolgreicher als die isolierten
einzelkämpfern webers kinder wachsen
damit auf dass die tiere die sie jeden
tag auf dem hof des vaters sehen
irgendwann abgeholt werden und in einer
pfanne landen alle tiere außer dem vater
mike natürlich
und weil die banken andere gruppe wurde
deutschland muss einen rund ums meer so
oder so das stimmt ja ich habe mir jetzt
das nicht vorstellen ich bin eine
qantas-boeing / wissen die fahrer sitzen
nicht so jagt vorstellen aber ich war
nie andere kulturen aufgewachsen weil
das für mich auch völlig ganz normal
dass man einen hund ist oder auch an
helen gerber fühlte sich tieren schon
immer nahe diese tiefe verbundenheit ist
nicht anerzogen sie war einfach dass sie
beim schlafen und und ihnen nachmachen
die sprache verstehen sie was hinter der
sache natürlich klinik noch mit einem
gemacht dass ein erhöhtes wenn man es
ist noch nicht geklärt ob es natürlich
nicht die sprache sie fordert von ihnen
später erklärt mit 40 aber das schon als
kind probiert was als ja nicht so ist es
nicht dabei ist es nicht einfach wenn er
mit dem abi dhabi company may bin ich
und was mit belasten
einfach wichtig
martin bühlmann ist ganz anders
aufgewachsen
im ortsmuseum seiner heimatgemeinde
hochdorf ist der vergangenheit der
region und damit auch seine eigene
konserviert eine vergangenheit in der
auch katzen in die schublade nutztiere
gehörten also zu den tieren denen man
nicht zu nahe kam
wobei diese scharfe trennlinie freilich
nicht nur zwischen mensch und tier
sondern auch zwischen menschen verlaufen
kann
wir mögen schwarz-weiß wir mögen
entweder oder wir mögen klare meinung
klare positionierung das macht das leben
leichter und es ist auch für das
funktionieren eines menschen einfacher
klare dinge klare ausrichtung zu haben
obwohl wir wissen dass die wenigsten
dinge schwarz oder weiß sind sondern
viele dinge sind sowohl als auch sind
differenzierter aber das ist etwas was
uns von unserem wahrnehmungsmuster nicht
entgegenkommt wir mögen das nicht mögen
nicht komplizierte differenzierte dinge
sondern wir mögen einfache klare schwarz
weiß muster sind denn die grenze sehr
stark auf dem weg zur könig zur eigene
gruppen abbrechen er quert und wer
überhaupt ein mensch die grenzen sind
absolut flexibel und veränderbar und je
nach situation kann einmal eine
bestimmte person innerhalb dieser
grenzen sein und in einer anderen
situation außerhalb der grenzen
man sieht das ja gut zum beispiel bei
sportereignissen wo eine nachbarstadt
feindlich erlebt wird wenn die
nachbarstadt gegen die eigene stadt
fußball spielt und wenn sie in der
nationalmannschaft zusammen spielen dann
sind die spieler die ich eben noch
negativ beurteilt hat vielleicht gehasst
habt sind meine lieblinge war sie jetzt
für die größere gemeinsame sache mit
kämpfen die emotionalen grundlinien sind
indes stabil in bremens fall das
katholische docma ausgehen
tagen das fleischeslust anstößig ist der
verzehr von fleisch dagegen ein
emotionaler höhepunkt etwa beim besuch
der großmutter großmutter wird oder
versetzte hat geht er jeden serie aller
spenden und durch studien als ich den
vertrieb es soll natürlich der ganze
wald zeigt wo ist die frau die
verdächtigt für sie ganz anders jetzt
voller teils jetzt ist mir klar dass ich
beste der zehn tage bevor während dieser
gefühlter dem tag was ist erstmal eine
dose cola kann ganz fertig ist
[Musik]
ein glück dass viel tiefer ging als das
was der glaube ihm lange geben konnte
[Musik]
eine wirkliche freude am glauben
entdeckte erst jetzt im alter wie fest
dass der hai - ganz konservative
katholische video fragt wurde wie
motörhead verständliche und der schule
für frauen von der who
doch die frohe botschaft nicht so
gespürt aber jetzt habe ich das richtig
dass du willst gut das geht es auf stufe
und das wird der gemeinschaftsleiter bis
schönste
[Musik]
luca verbringt seinen sommer in der
gemeinschaft von seinesgleichen auf
einer alp im sanktgallischen weißtannen
teil weit und breit kein mensch der
versuchen würde
in ihm mehr zu sehen als ein nutztier
[Musik]
ganz anders bei den tieren von helen
gerbers kunden neben ihren seminaren
lebt die tierkommunikatorin vor allem
von telefonberatungen für gut 100
franken pro halbe stunde hilft sie
menschen die das gefühl haben ihre
vierbeiner hätten ihnen etwas zu sagen
in diesem fall ein hund namens bruder
sie machen für die aus was sie tue ich
für die damit der gurke damit drucks und
blickt damit / knies mit lernschwächen
sich auf derartige schöpft sie von gott
geschenkt hätte der konzern hat
allerdings nicht nur einen
sendungsauftrag sondern auch ein
handfestes problem nämlich die katze die
sein frauchen kürzlich angeschafft hat
frage was sagst du dazu dass es hat mir
ist das klingt so lange sie man jetzt
hats immer saniert und die frage warum
nicht der groß glienicker see sieht es
muss für sie sie mit vielleicht drei
vier jahre von einer hat sich geschüttet
wurde da hat das nicht immer das problem
zu betrachten ist euer hund hat der hund
mit der situation nicht umgehen kerbe
schlägt schließlich vor die situation
mit einer art schutzzone für blut zu
entschärfen
es gehört viel ich danke frau spielt das
blitzen
ja ja ich bin ein professionell sagen
ihr beispiel professionell und skater
die bcc berufsjahr familien die caritas
der telepathie macht schon lange
wenn es wirklich so absurd es dem user
das schmeckt heute zwischen
[Musik]
vier monate das immer hrung in den
bergen kehren die vier hürden ins
unterland zurück ja es seine tiere
vermisst sagt weber auch luca denn bald
ein jahr alt wird
ja sehr einen schönen moment vor allem
aber ich sehe etwas alle gesund sind und
dass all die red bull kommen und da ja
schon wunderbare schöne momente
[Musik]
auf der einen seite ist da diese echte
tiefe freude und auf der anderen seite
webers blick der auch der eines
geschäftsmannes ist er mit diesen tieren
geld verdient dass dir dass ich jetzt
dann stehe ich jetzt zwei monate und
wird wahrscheinlich schnitt schlachthof
oder - die mets begriffen aktien schwanz
auszutreten
ich muss ein größerer teil väter dass
man die tiere von schlachter mit mehr
qualität und preis hat und das wird sie
hätten aber die hand sollten dass ich
habe dann der unterschied punkten also
wahrscheinlich unter store ist ein mann
in stahl und lebten noch fertig vorteile
luca ist und bleibt schlacht wie
[Musik]
julian vom hasen schreck kurz theologe
land hatte derweil die möglichkeit etwas
ganz anderes zu werden und hätte einfach
der alltag gefilmt haben sie dass die
banker das ist 12 glücklicher jahre
später forderte die natur jedoch ihren
tribut
romantisch roth ja auswirken
das nicht dass der arzt der deutschland
würde die pflege der heimischen straßen
zu machen
wieso
aus anderen folgten
wir haben das potenzial tiere zu geben
und tiere zu töten
und manchmal töten wir sie auch weil wir
sie lieben
sogar hellen gerber kennt es als ein
schwerkranker fuchs vor ihrer tür
auftauchte holte sie ihre waffe blut
durch und legte an
was ist das für ein gefühl wenn es dir
sie ist krass krasniqi frau aus niemegk
machte als die heime und ich bin froh
wenn ist ja nicht brauchen
das musik und klassik füchsen die anrede
leiden kann man eigentlich nur mit einer
kugel helfen
das lernte hellen gerber in einer jagd
ausbildung die sie angefangen hatte weil
sie mehr erfahren wollte über wildtiere
die dir dich schlaf ich heut ja unser
alltag besteht allerdings nicht aus
extremsituationen sondern aus routinen
und automatismen für reto weber unter
anderem aus einem 50 prozent pensum im
dienste eines schlachtvieh großhändlers
in dessen auftrag er regelmäßig bauern
besucht
[Musik]
diese noch einer
es gibt verschiedene label und die haben
für den jahr vorträge gewicht und das
macht das heißt von der festigkeit und
so weiter und dort und jetzigen berater
und sagen weil es dir das mobile kanal
einfach auf damit erreichte bestmöglich
stelle es hat das ist das ziel
hier geht es also nicht um
persönlichkeiten sondern um zahn nummern
und lebens
aber knapp
[Musik]
ich habe es 2008 nur so durch
massentierhaltung und spätere
industrielle tötung ist er stetig
steigende fleischkonsum unserer
gesellschaft zu befriedigen
auch wenn wir die konsumenten darunter
viele tierfreunde es oft lieber nicht zu
genau wissen wollen wer stark vernebelt
dass ich das das land plant das ist es
die liebe muss sterbe ich esse zwar
fleisch aber das team muss sterben
und das ist natürlich der manchen autos
plant das ist die gleiche wie war mir
egal welche träume hat wird schnell mit
ganz schlechter warnt lüth eigentlich
nie externen und haben den abstand vor
dem geschrieben man schnell ob die
obergrenze
man fühlt sich wohler wenn man nicht
permanent mit vermeintlichen
widersprüchen konfrontiert wird und wir
haben als menschen generell die tendenz
nicht dass wir das suchen sondern dass
wir das er gar nicht hören wollen oder
sofort uminterpretieren wir kennen das
aus der politik dieses phänomen ich habe
eine grundüberzeugung und ich bekomme
irgendwelche fakten präsentiert und in
der regel werde ich aber nicht aufgrund
der fakten meine grundüberzeugung ändern
sondern der regeln werde ich die fakten
so biegen dass sie meine
grundüberzeugung reinpassen
und wenn es sachen sind die bei einer
grund überzogen total widersprechen
dann werde ich tendenziell eine
erklärung haben würde sagen die zahlen
stimmen gar nicht oder ich bin bewusst
manipuliert worden
also es funktioniert nicht sehr stark im
sinne von da sind fakten und die gehen
sofort relativieren die überzeugung wir
haben ganz starkes festhalten an
grundüberzeugungen grundmustern und
haben eher die tendenz alles was dem
widerspricht nicht sehen zu wollen um zu
interpretieren und damit diese spannung
gar nicht aufkommen zu lassen
ein nachruf schlimmer die zwölf wochen
halten wird den schwersten des wolfes
nach hause prägten das bei würde zogen
und umgekehrt
das baby habe aber wie so ein nachruf
für das tier also das wird man ja
normalerweise für den mensch machen ja
jüdische der form von menschlicher mich
hat er seine hufe blüht kann ja gleich
und medien mit 104 bundes sie sind oder
was davon wahr
und wenn man kleine schritte sind sie
verschickt da hat also internetadresse
15 21 kann ich da schon in der welt
ungeschickt oder ab gab aber schon ganz
gezielt das einzige rückmeldungen
positiv
der tod eines tieres kann entweder eine
tragödie für uns sein oder eine zahl in
der buchhaltung
was für ein wort hat dann dass die
grenze so fertig großer finanzieller
werden das lied das würde zwar sagen so
2800 franken
ungefähr werde ich jetzt mal sagen ja
das unternehmen von flüssigkeit tvs dass
für die gleiche kerbe wie csi aber mir
hat gemurrt bekannte scheine kleinkriegs
im vor allem ist allerdings sicher dass
der zuschlag auf und die regel haben
die ersten sind schon schwächen und der
von ihm haben auch die presse der
genetiker und ich nehme viel mehr
erbringen von der flasche greifen wieder
auch ein schwerer unfall muss man
sprachwitz besserung
[Musik]
fox des städtischen anteils zwei jahren
schon unter bild der parkleiter ist das
ja letztes jahr gestorben sind alles
harten und rüden ja ja ja ja also wenn
man das programm jetzt hamma jaschin
das geht glaubt 25
dank hätten tatsächlich spitze landtages
bitten und der hund julian vom nassen
strecke und ich halte
romantiker handeln dass sie in der in
riga ein hund hat ja wenn es billig zu
haben das waren zwar ganz gut geschlagen
und es ist natürlich mit dem shuttle vom
bund ja also mit dem hund einfach wie
ich es bin ich doch sehr wie bist du sie
ich habe mich verändert rechte bis zur
kurve und interhome bedenke mensch dass
du staub bist und zum staub zurückkehren
lässt
luca hingegen wird heute nicht zu staub
sondern zu wiederholten ihr stück und
ähnlichem
zeit sich gedanken über seine nach hof
zu machen und sie mit dem tier ein
spezieller charakter würde ich jetzt
nicht sagen
es ist nett dass die ruhig sehr
spezielle spiele es extrem zynisch oder
extrem mild oder so geordnet sondern
sich es ist absolut unauffällig
[Musik]
und so tritt luca seinen letzten gang
nach anderthalb jahren an ohne jemand
gewesen zu sein
sozusagen als mini ohne eigenschaften 20
die direkte hand und müsste die werde
der heutige überlappen auch die nerven
nein danke wir machen dann hätte sich
der vorsprung für sich michael pachter
vor dem tier oder von der us kette zu
sich leben und sterben auf den bauern
hoffen dass das gehört einfach dazu habe
am fleisch aus dass die zwei jahre
[Musik]
möhlmann am tatort dort wo er julian vom
hasen schreck seinen geliebten schüler
in die ewigen jagdgründe befördert hat
etwas wovon sie sich verabschiedet
so
was also ist jetzt dass ich wirklich das
ist für mich schlimm zur koch schlimm
also de cuisine konsequenz soja fleisch
kann ob es das augenmittel ja ja absolut
stelle jeder für das soffin der kreis
würde ich das nicht mache meine tore
christoph spaziert oder die täter
geschubst damit man hier nicht dass es
das ist was ich nit passt nicht zusammen
so verzichtet sie dann konsequent wie so
viele kräfte nach halt macht
mehrere flaschen mit dem ich wieder ganz
wir selber dann durchsichtig es geht
doch nicht mit fisch ist genau sondern
mit worden sie sind einfach ein
fleischfresser
also ja ja das war nicht schön dass ich
versuche es möglich ist mit masken
möglichst viel wie nötig so wenig wie
möglich was für fleisch also zusammen
also ich meistens landfläche
[Musik]
luca im wartesaal zum tod
wer keine angst wir zeigen ihnen nicht
wie er gleich mit einem bolzenschuss
betreut wird und sie müssen sich auch
nicht ansehen wie er anschließend
ausblutet und zerlegt
[Musik]
beim medizin zeige wie eines tier
geschlachtet wird die meisten fernseher
abstellen ja so war das nicht schön ist
anzusehen weil es unbequem ist weil es
gegen die eigenen verhaltensweisen
vielleicht im widerspruch gerät und wir
mögen nicht unangenehme unbequeme dinge
die im widerspruch zu unseren
grundüberzeugungen zu unserem täglichen
handelns stehen
[Musik]
sie möchten luca so in erinnerung
behalten nicht wahr obwohl sie genau
wissen dass das nur ein teil der
wahrheit ist gut wir tun ihnen den
gefallen
[Musik]
die meisten menschen vertragen die
realität offenbar nur in kleinen dosen
[Musik]
dog mit toyota auris hybrid
er braucht keine steckdose und fährt
trotzdem elektrisch